[Música]
[Aplausos] a
maioria de vocês já foi a uma
apresentação ao vivo antes, seja para
assistir seus filhos se apresentando na escola ou
indo a um concerto para uma
apresentação de dança no teatro ou até mesmo
assistindo a uma apresentação de rua ou uma
palestra do TED, mas a maioria  de vocês têm essa
experiência lembrem-se de como se sentem podem se
sentir muito empolgados com isso
vocês realmente querem estar lá ou talvez
tiveram um dia muito longo vocês estão cansados e
não com o humor certo para estarem lá mas
lá estão vocês naquele momento em que  as
luzes se apagam e aqueles segundos de
silêncio antes da performance
começar são cruciais e para o
performer eles são fundamentais então vamos tentar
lembrar dessa experiência e eu não
sei você mas para mim é como mudar
para uma dimensão diferente é  como ser
uma realidade diferente
e muitas vezes há todas essas
emoções que estou me acomodando sentindo
e é tão avassalador que eu sinto isso no meu
corpo na minha pele e isso drena toda a
energia e é tão poderoso e
transformador e ma  ny vezes no final
da performance as pessoas começam a
comentar como foi incrível e eu não
posso deixar alguns minutos só para descer
absorver toda aquela experiência toda aquela
intensidade e então eu estou pronto para voltar
para a realidade e isso  nem
eu estava apenas no palco eu estava apenas na platéia então o que
acontece lá o que acontece por trás daquelas
cortinas que fazem os artistas trazer para
nós toda aquela experiência transformadora poderosa
a questão é então o que faz uma grande
performance e o que faz um grande
artista e  é sobre isso que quero
falar hoje as mesmas questões vêm
orientando e inspirando pesquisadores em
psicologia e outras ciências há muitos
anos eles tentam
entender a excelência no desempenho e
podemos vê-la de três maneiras diferentes ou
através de abordagens diferentes uma
delas  quem pensa em excelência em pesquisa
como resultado de algum tipo de dom, você
precisa ter uma habilidade inata ou
herdada, mas você precisa dessa habilidade e,
claro, você é um  Também preciso de um
ambiente estimulante e ter as pessoas certas
que o ajudem a transformar esse presente em
talento, mas o foco está na ideia de que
você precisa de um presente, então há um segundo
grupo que se concentra na ideia de trabalho duro,
eles realmente criticam esse primeiro
grupo  e dizer não o que você precisa é
realmente treinar duro para trabalhar duro e é
aí que, por exemplo, surge o conceito de
prática deliberada ou a ideia de que você
precisa de 10.000 horas para se tornar um especialista
e aspirar a tantas pessoas e
pesquisadores em muitos domínios, mas aqui  o
foco é o trabalho árduo
treinamento adequado, então há um terceiro
grupo que Lucas considera a excelência
como resultado de ter algum tipo de conhecimento
especializado em sabedoria na maneira como você lida e
entende os aspectos complexos, significativos
e complicados e incertos da
vida, portanto, um excelente performer
também seria um artista sábio agora quando se trata
de entender o desempenho humano nos
níveis mais altos, aqueles que realmente sabem
sobre isso são o psicólogo esportivo para
s  as pessoas da ciência eles realmente têm as
ferramentas as medidas os laboratórios
e nós aprendemos muito com eles então
talvez você não saiba mas agora nós colocamos
músicos e dançarinos em esteiras
correndo para medir seus níveis de condicionamento
ou nós os conectamos para medir sua frequência
cardíaca  e até tiramos
amostras de saliva para medir seu cortisol para
tentar entender o estresse e na verdade quando
tento explicar o que faço e sou
psicólogo e pesquisador em
ciência da performance trabalho com artistas
geralmente tenho que aceitar para dar um
exemplo  e dizer oh, eu sou uma espécie de
psicólogo esportivo para artistas e então as
pessoas entendem bem que não são
os mesmos atletas e artistas podem ser
muito semelhantes em muitos aspectos, mas
também são muito diferentes e eu quero
contar um pouco mais  sobre a
vida de um artista performático esta é
uma sala de ensaio é onde os performers
passam a maior parte do seu dia na verdade a maior parte da
sua vida e como podem ver
não há muitas distracções apenas o que
é  absolutamente necessário desenvolver uma
habilidade para desenvolver um talento na verdade esta
é uma sala muito boa porque há uma
janela sorte então há alguma luz
luz natural agora nessa sala você
também pode ver que há um espelho e esse
espelho é onde os artistas aprendem a ver
seus  erros e para corrigir seus
erros esse espelho pode ter um
impacto enorme em sua auto-estima sua
confiança e sua identidade e esse
espelho reflete não só como eles
se vêem seu auto julgamento, mas também
reflete todos nós membros da
audiência família pesquisadores professores
que  esperar que eles tenham um desempenho nos
níveis mais altos o tempo todo muita
pressão eles vivem sob
pressão
constante julgamento constante pressão e
estresse constantes para que eles possam ter um desempenho no
nível mais alto agora eles precisam desenvolver
as habilidades em uma sala como essa e isso
também pode  seja uma dança para D por exemplo
para poder mostrar suas habilidades em uma
sala como esta e tocar se apresentar
lindamente agora como eles fazem  que bem
temos escolas e
instituições profissionais muito boas que dão a
esses artistas todas as melhores condições
que podem ter para que possam desenvolver
suas habilidades para que possam
praticar muito e serem capazes de transformar
e transferir todas essas habilidades para uma sala
como  isso e só para dar um
exemplo no Royal College of Music em
Londres temos um simulador de performance
onde os alunos podem ir e se apresentar na
frente de uma platéia virtual ou um
painel de audição e perceber como é
estar em uma sala como aquela
agora isso não acontece em todos os lugares, mas
ainda as escolas e
situações profissionais dão o seu melhor para ajudar esses
artistas a estarem no mais alto nível em uma
sala como as coisas agora também sabemos que os
artistas são altamente motivados,
pessoas altamente apaixonadas, trabalham muito duro,
mas também amam  o que eles fazem eles são
perfeccionistas e isso significa que eles
empurram seus limites ao limite o
tempo todo e eles também são muito organizados
eles precisam ser  porque cada hora de suas
vidas é preciosa, eles precisam
ter esse tempo para
aperfeiçoar suas habilidades, então sabemos de tudo isso que
eles são pessoas altamente motivadas que
há reservas disponíveis para ajudá-
los a fazer isso agora talvez você não veja
isso  quando você vai a uma apresentação ao vivo,
mas há um lado menos glamouroso na
vida de um artista e deixe-me contar
um pouco sobre isso, os
artistas trabalharão muito, muito duro para
realmente serem capazes de se apresentar e ganhar a
vida com isso, o que significa que  eles passam
muitas horas do dia praticando indo
a audições indo a competições para
conseguir um emprego mas na maioria das vezes esses
trabalhos são por períodos curtos então eles
na verdade precisam de vários empregos para pagar as
contas para poder comer e assim por diante então
eles  tem que continuar praticando ir para
adições a competições tem vários
empregos seu equilíbrio entre vida profissional e pessoal é uma bagunça
as condições de trabalho são muito ruins e à medida
que envelhecem como você pode imaginar as coisas
não ficam mais fáceis
então carreiras sus  sustentabilidade é realmente um
problema para os artistas, também sabemos que
eles não descansam ou se exercitam
adequadamente porque têm uma vida muito ocupada
, trabalham em horas anti-sociais e, por
exemplo, temos estudos recentes que mostram
que os artistas estão em alto risco de
distúrbios do sono, o que  pode ter um enorme
impacto na capacidade cognitiva e motora
que eles precisam para executar nos
níveis mais altos, também sabemos que os
pesquisadores que pesquisas mostram que os
artistas não são muito bons em pedir
ajuda,
então sua saúde e atitude em relação à
saúde não são ótimas, eles geralmente pedem
ajuda ao professor primeiro eles seguem
suas orientações e depois talvez possam
pedir a ajuda de seus amigos ou familiares
e quando não aguentam
mais procuram ajuda profissional e por que
isso acontece porque mostra que você
tem um problema no  artes cênicas é
mostrar que você tem uma fraqueza você pode
mostrar porque se você mostrar
alguém vai te substituir imediatamente e
essa pessoa que vai r  no lugar de
você provavelmente é seu amigo porque
eles são amigos
também são concorrentes diretos então isso
traz muitos desafios físicos e psicológicos
sabemos que os artistas sofrem de alta
incidência de lesões dores físicas e
outros problemas musculoesqueléticos eles são
eles não são pés como eles provavelmente
precisam  ser para enfrentar toda a demanda física de se
apresentar como eu disse antes eles
não são ótimos para dar ajuda profissional
para lidar com esses problemas e a liberação
vem também problemas psicológicos
há uma alta incidência de medo do palco
ansiedade desempenho depressão e outros
problemas de saúde mental e  sabemos que
durante muito tempo as pesquisas continuam a
mostrar que estes são os principais
problemas entre os artistas performativos
recentemente num estudo em que
estamos envolvidos descobrimos que, por exemplo, os
estudantes de música usam muito pouco as habilidades de lidar
com todo o stress e pressão
que vivem  desde tenra idade,
esperamos que eles sejam capazes de gerenciar o
estresse de maneira muito eficaz  y como eles
fazem bem muito mal eles na verdade
não fazem não fazem muito bem
e este estudo mostra que não estamos
ajudando eles a desenvolver as habilidades para serem
capazes de lidar com toda essa pressão isso
traz muitos outros problemas  e isso mostra
como a vida de um performer pode ser menos
glamourosa agora o que nos falta aqui
temos todas essas informações sobre
como fazer um grande performer mas estamos
perdendo algo e eu diria que o
que nos falta é ver a pessoa que
ser humano por trás do performer há
uma pessoa lá e muitas vezes nos esquecemos disso
e todos nós queremos ver uma grande
performance e não percebemos que
isso vem muitas vezes a grande
despesa das escolas de performers e
instituições profissionais e
pesquisadores que estamos tentando nosso  melhor
dar aos artistas suas melhores condições para se
destacar estamos realmente trabalhando duro para
isso e em alguns países e temos
sorte o suficiente no Reino Unido de ter isso, mas
isso não acontece em muitos lugares,
especialmente em sm  aller schools por
exemplo ou empresas mais pequenas mas
já existem alguns cuidados de saúde e
apoio de saúde para artistas performativos
apoio de carreira para artistas performativos
apoio especializado agora o problema é
que continuamos a olhar para o performer como
parte de um corpo frações de um performer
e enquanto  fazemos isso podemos ser podemos
não perceber que por trás daquele performer
talvez haja um corpo partido uma
mente quebrada um coração partido ou mesmo o risco de
uma carreira quebrada e nenhum de nós quer que
na ciência da performance estudemos
performance entendamos a complexidade
da performance  e para fazer isso
, usamos lentes diferentes e compartilhamos lentes
, aprendemos com outros domínios e
precisamos fazer isso para ter uma ideia clara
do quadro geral
, precisamos usar abordagens allistic e
abrangentes, agora a
evidência está lá, sabemos o que  faz um
ótimo desempenho, mas também sabemos que
tipo de desafio eles enfrentam, então para mim
é muito simples, vamos apenas usar essas
evidências e reuni-las
porque se nós como membros do público
como professores como família como pesquisadores
indivíduos ou instituições que trabalham
com artistas performáticos
se queremos ter
performers ainda maiores e grandes
performances precisamos conhecer a
pessoa que precisamos para empoderar aquele
ser humano que está por trás  o performer e
essa é a única maneira de desfrutar de uma
experiência transformadora através de um ótimo
desempenho e, ao fazer isso,
provavelmente teremos artistas com desempenho
melhor, mais saudável e por mais tempo, obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]